so John for your career how much acting
work have you booked on your own and how
much have you relied on agent hahaha and
how do you feel about both roles and
about one how do you feel about both
roles and which which which roles in
which others are more fulfilling once
you've booked on your own or once once
we started the studio and started doing
doing what we want to do in Louisiana I
no longer saw a need for representation
there's a line in a movie we just
finished my guy says that's a
distraction distraction happens you know
that's you're not doing what you don't
want to do because of life because life
got in the way you got distracted
distracted happens i think that the
those other kinds of jobs are
distractions I really do I think I do
believe without getting all spiritual
and supernatural on you I I do believe
that there are forces that will try to
get a focused individual or team of
individuals off their game because a
team of individuals who are focused
can't help but do good things for those
they come in contact with and I do
believe there's stuff out there that
wants to squelch that at every possible
opportunity so those things I believe
are distractions I thank God every day
for the haves and have-nots working with
with Tyler Perry on the oprah winfrey
network is an amazing an amazing actor
job and it's an amazing school for me to
learn and I was not I told both of them
I said I was not ready to learn anything
after 50 I didn't think there was
anything else I needed to know because I
was still working on the lessons I had
and that came through a
that that job came through an agent the
rest of the work since then has come
through relationships not getting rich
by that stuff at all but doing very
interesting different kinds of things
like Alicia was talking about if you
come to the studio and do a movie you're
going to be doing a character no one
else will probably want you to do or
allow you to do or consider you to do so
I get off on that as an actor but as far
as as far as representation I don't
think John Schneider doesn't have time
for it right now John Schneider studios
and the movies that we're doing needs
representation the movies they need
representation I don't and life gets
better after 50 life gets so much better
after it's all a game until you turn 50
and then it's really fun why because
you're doing what you know you can do
you no longer worried about I mean
everybody's younger than you so you're
no longer thinking oh my goodness what
are the adults gonna think screw them
were the adults now I'm not there yet
that's true that's true mentally I'm 80
you